INTERVIEWER: So the
Egyptian military recently
announced that it's building
a number of fish farms
right on the border with Gaza.
That seems like a weird
thing for Egypt to be doing
and an even weirder
place to be doing it.
And weirder still, Egypt
sees the fish farms
as part of their
counter-terrorism strategy.
As you might have
guessed, there's
a lot more going on here.
The site of the
future fisheries is
Rafah, a town that
sits half in Egypt
and a half in the Gaza Strip.
The border cuts right
down the middle.
That border became a
very big deal in 2007
when the organization
Hamas took control of Gaza.
Hamas' military arm was a big
security concern for both Egypt
and Israel, and both
countries basically
closed their borders with Gaza.
This has meant a severe
blockade of the Gaza Strip.
The flow of goods in and
out is extremely limited.
For Gazans, the blockade has
inspired some creativity,
namely a network of secret
tunnels between the Gazan
and Egyptian sides of Rafah.
The tunnels have been used to
smuggle in all manner of goods
from fuel, construction
materials, and tools
to dry foods, cigarettes,
and livestock.
It's been a big
industry for years
with some estimates placing
the number of tunnels
in the thousands.
Depending on who
you ask, the tunnels
are either a godsend or a curse.
Israel has called them
arteries of terror out of fear
that they're helping
weapons get to Hamas.
Hamas, on the other hand,
happily collects taxes
on anything passing
through the tunnels
and has admitted to getting
weapons that way too.
And then there's Egypt.
The Egyptian military has long
feared that the tunnels could
allow terrorists to
sneak across the border
and has done a lot shutter them.
In 2009, they built
an underground wall
almost 60 feet deep
beneath the crossing.
Smugglers breached
it within a year.
In 2013, they pumped raw
sewage into the tunnels.
Smugglers presumably
plugged their noses.
And then, this past
August, the military
began construction of the fish
farms, which sounds ridiculous,
except that it involved pumping
untold gallons of seawater
into the border area, which
utterly swamped the tunnel
system.
According to one
anonymous tunnel builder,
the result was devastating.
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
SUBJECT 1 INTERPRETER:
They have destroyed
everything in 20 days.
During the 50-day war,
the Israeli rockets
couldn't do such a thing,
and 10 days after the war,
we were able to get
this business back.
But now we are unable to
get our businesses back.
All the tunnels have collapsed.
INTERVIEWER: The ruination
of the tunnel system
is great news for the Egyptian
military, bad news for Hamas,
but maybe the worst news of
all for the Gazan people.
Legal or otherwise, the tunnels
were an employer in Rafah
and an important release
valve for the pressures
of the blockade.
All of that may be gone
now, which is really
just the latest in a
series of hardships
for the residents of Rafah.
Most of them are refugees
and their families
displaced from Israel
as long ago as 1948.
Many were separated
from family and friends
when the border split
the town in two.
And they've seen
homes and buildings
demolished by
Israel in an attempt
to route out the tunnels.
Now those tunnels
are gone, and they're
left wondering
just what is going
on across that border in Egypt.
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
SUBJECT 2 (INTERPETER):
We respect our neighbors.
We love the Egyptians,
because we are connected,
and we are relatives.
But our neighbors are
making our lives harder.
They have caused
us a lot of damage.
INTERVIEWER: To see the fallout
from another very different
kind of flood, one that may
or may not have been man
made, check out this
episode about oil
drilling in the world's
largest mud volcano.
This is a satellite image of
Perang, Indonesia in 2004.
This is that same place in 2008.
What happened in
between those two photos
wasn't an earthquake
or a typhoon,
it was one of the most
mysterious natural disasters
in memory.
And if you haven't
already, subscribe
to Secret Stories to make
sure you get all our videos,
and thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]